it's all aric it's it's it's an archaic
form of government all right all right
how's your [__] house going at the
[Laughter]
moment we'll take five suggestions then
we'll drop a beat do a freestyle rap
we'll start with uh this this segment in
the room hello suggestion number one
what would you like a freestyle rap
about Parliament you're you're an
American man you are cool do you do you
know anything about it no oh lovely
stuff you feel like the perfect time to
learn is in a comedy show in rhyming
format that's Parliament I love it thank
you so much well I mean if you had to if
you had to describe like give me give me
a brief pressy of how you conceptualize
the parliament what do you know about it
I'm so happy my dates in the bathroom
you're so happy your dates in the
bathroom that sounds threatening doesn't
it um form of government it's AR it's
it's it's an archaic form of government
all right all right how's your [__]
house going at the
[Laughter]
moment I mean it's archaic but it
functions
um okay let's let's get suggestion
number two we'll come to we back of the
room we'll get one from you guys back of
the room what you want wrap
up Britney oh of course topical relevant
her her Memoir I suppose can you call it
a memoir it feels very kind of protect
just when people put out a biography go
actually it's a memoir like I'll be the
[__] judge of that this is a
biography [__] calm down that's okay
she refers to herself as a [__] so it's
not offensive great so Britney Britney
uh and it's called The woman Inside Me
isn't it that's pretty
pretty why not front this side of the
room what would you like a wrap
about kindergarten getting sick in front
of everybody a kindergartener getting
sick in front of everybody I I take it
that that's from your day job it's a
very visceral moment to kind of bring up
are you are you do work in a
kindergarten I do you do there you go
what how how visible was the sickness
was it projectile was it was it
projectile projectile both ends a little
bit a little bit oh gosh I didn't know
great that's in terms of the laws of
physics how does that
work just every Newton right this
this section what do you want to WP
about Princess Diana Princess Diana okay
yeah what aspect of her life do you want
us to focus on and don't be
mean Prince Charles cheating on her
Prince Charles cheating on her great
Prince Charles cheating on princess a
kindergarten being sick in front of
everyone from both or offices um Britney
and Parliament is naric for of
government final suggestion from the
final section don't let you're putting a
hand up this is a lot of responsibility
this is someone going I think I can nail
this Chris I think I can beat the [__]
out of all of these ones yeah yeah what
would you like a wrap about Halloween
Halloween oh lovely stuff what what are
you going to be dressing as a mom a
mom are are you a mother yes okay cool
[Applause]
lazy not in your day-to-day life
obviously it's a very hard job but I
have not even thought about what I was
going to focused on are you focused on
the kids what are you dressing the kids
as um a very a fairy queen Mickey Mouse
Mickey Mouse and um a cat and a cat
three children in New York City [__]
loaded mate all
right a fairy
queen I forgot on the middle one Micky
mous Mickey Mouse New Jersey oh that's
fine
um how's trick-or treating in New Jersey
how does that how does that work festive
festive oh it's not the adjective I
would have
expected right that's what we're going
to do uh my lovely band they're going to
provide the musical accompaniment do
different yeah do always do something a
different red R oh is this oh
spooky my God it's like the hammer house
of horror well this is a freestyle based
on all those suggestions Halloween mom
about Britany and her Memoir we'll call
it that Parliament being an archaic form
of government I'm I'm pretty excited for
this this is going to be cool the
kindergarten having a sickness in front
of you and Prince
Charles he had a wife but he didn't want
to Slammer misunderstanding he's like
Miss Diana you and I don't see eye to
eye so I'm going with Camila she's the
Thriller outside he was stretching a
wide Diana sat there sad seven years on
dating fired that's the son of the guy
running Harris that's the London store
sadly came to an end but had fun before
Prince Charles ever so clear Diana so
hot that prick got the large ears why
would you hook him yeah we know she's
like one day that Bast to be on the
throne but sadly never lasted to the end
Britany my gosh I depended on her
lustful looks with a school girl skirt
Hit Me Baby One More Time Yeah it
couldn't hurt but she wrote a whole book
yes I'm the rapper talking about how she
sat there pen in the chapters working
through the day she pulled an all
nighter obviously not she used a ghost
writer still that's the woman inside her
I'd go so far to say a top class Memoir
I know it's rocketing up the charts
everybody's look she aborted Justin's
fetus in this book people were shocked
they were open in their mouth Mike
Johnson the new speaker of the house
wouldn't like that he's like no placenta
free I'd be believ in the laws from the
century 18th it's what he said like back
in the day they were picking a speaker
then another every day then he came up
what is he like magam Mike that's a guy
he could really Insight Another January
6th and let me say that's never happened
in UK my country Tre no one's ever
stormed Parliament no one got upset and
then they went we're going to take it
apart we're going to burn it down even
though they're so old they look like
they melt down into dust it kind of
matches like Snap Parliament aric like
it's way back well of course we have a
mace and a sword and then you've got the
part the House of Lords that's old fusty
guys in their 80s they would be Chuck
Schumer's matey I love the ladies who
dress their kids looking so fly you want
to be Mickey Mouse go outside you have
to start 4:30 quite early cuz after 6:00
don't go to New Jersey people sit there
on the property a fairy queen now you're
not getting none off of me I keep my
candy and in comes another one but well
done Halloween yeah you're a very
organized Mom no costume for yourself I
hope both of your kids are in rude
Health well all three actually I hope
they're not starting chundering there at
the front of kindergarten one tiny child
a little toddler he says my tummy feels
wobbly it starts vomiting oh what do you
think last night did your parents feed
you bad shrimp do you start projecting
there from the front and the back and
all the teachers start to feel a panic
attack they're like ah I never saw
before there we go a freestyle rapper
hope you all
[Applause]
[Music]
adore ah lovely stuff you guys are very
nice my name is first Tona thank you
very much
goodbye